fermé pour cause de grève reconnaissons
que voilà un écriteau que l'on n'a guère
l'habitude de voir placardée sur la
porte de nos médecins
c'était pourtant le cas aujourd'hui même
si les médecins contestataires
l'établissent un subtil distinguo entre
ce mot de grève qu'ils récusent le terme
deux journées nationales l'avertissement
qu'il revendique but de leur action
protester contre la menace de dépôt de
déconventionnement pardon de 600 de
leurs confrères à qui l'on reproche
d'avoir dépassé des tarifs
conventionnels c'est à dire les tarifs
de la sécurité sociale
tous les médecins ne sont pas d'accord
sur ce mouvement décidées par la
confédération des syndicats médicaux de
france et la cfdt elle-même le juge
étroitement corporatiste
ils étaient plusieurs milieux cet après
midi des invalides à la gare
montparnasse à l'origine de cette
manifestation
la confédération des syndicats médicaux
qui représente environ 60% des
praticiens conséquence de cette journée
nationale d'avertissement 20% de
cabinets fermés à paris et une bonne
moitié en province car les médecins
n'ont pas le droit de grève quand ils
sont mécontents
le code leur interdit de cesser le
travail partout donc des permanences de
soins ont été assurés le conflit n'est
pas nouveau le régime conventionnel
repose sur un principe simple chaque
médecin s'engage à respecter des tarifs
d'honoraires fixé et par leur syndicat
et par la sécurité sociale
le système a bien marché jusqu'en mai
dernier date à laquelle les médecins ont
voulu appliquer leur propre tarif plus
élevé que ce qui était autorisé
c'est donc d'abord un problème d'argent
depuis des années nos honoraires sont
négociés ne sont pas libres deuxièmement
la médecine actuellement n'est plus la
médecine xixème siècle a porté la
science à chaque malade c'est apporter
toute une véritable installation qui est
coûteuse la gestion d'un cabinet avec du
personnel
c'est une petite entreprise au service
du malade qui est un prix de revient et
c'est justement ce prix de revient que
nous voulons qu'en 1977 et d'un années à
venir
nous voulons qu'ils soient pris en
considération dans le cas de nos
négociations avec les caisses avec le
gouvernement
comment voulez vous qu moment nous
demandons à l'ensemble du pays de faire
preuve de discipline nous puissions
céder à ce chantage quelconque on en est
pas encore là mais il est vrai que le
revenu des médecins reste très élevé
pour le centre d'études et de recherches
des coûts un spécialiste gagnent en
moyenne 225 mille francs par mois un
généraliste 200 mille francs
mais pour le gouvernement il n'est pas
question de remettre en cause pour
l'instant la médecine libérale au moment
où la dernière la dernière convention a
été signée les médecins avaient déjà
exprimé leur crainte de voir se créer
des centres de la sécurité sociale qui
fleure qu'il leur ferait une concurrence
et mettrait les mettrait en difficulté
or ça n'a pas été réalisé du tout et or
rien n'a été touché aux modalités
d'exercice des médecins
donc c'est uniquement une question de
tarification et je crois que cette
crainte de fonctionnarisation n'était
fondée en aucune façon d'ailleurs de
toute façon ce n'est pas la sécurité
sociale qui est maître d'oeuvre en la
matière ce sont les pouvoirs publics et
pouvoirs publics que sont tout à fait
délibérément
décidée à soutenir la médecine libérale
et à maintenir ce mode d'activité auquel
d'ailleurs les français sont attachés
n'empêche qu'au delà des problèmes
d'argent c'est tout le statut de la
médecine qui est une nouvelle fois mis
en cause c'est un choix autant politique
que social